what we're going to do in this video is
generalize what we did in the last video
and essentially end up with a formula
for rotating something around the x axis
like this using what we would call the
disk method and the point is to really
show you where that formula that you
might see in a calculus book actually
comes from that it just comes from the
exact same principles that we did in the
last video it's not for you to memorize
it formula I highly recommend against
that because then you really won't know
what's going on it's really just to do
it it's better to do it from first
principles where you find the volume of
each of these discs and think of it that
way but let's just generalize what we
saw in the last video so instead of
saying that this is y is equal to x
squared let's say that this is the graph
this function right over here this
function right over here let's just
generalize it and call it Y is equal to
f of X and instead of saying but we're
going between 0 & 2 let's just say we're
going between we're going between a and
B so these are just two endpoints along
the x axis so how would we find the
volume of this well just like the last
video we would still take a disk just
like this but what is the height of the
disk now well the height of the disk is
not just x squared we've generalized it
it is going to be whatever the value of
our function is at that point so the
height of the disk is going to be f of X
the area of this of the space of this
disk is going to be pi times our radius
squared so our radius is f of X and we
are just going to square it that's the
area that's the area of this face right
over here what is the volume of our disk
we're just have to multiply that times
our depth so it's going to be that times
DX and we want to take the sum of all of
these disks from A to B and we're going
to take the sum of them and then take
the limit as the DX is get smaller and
smaller and smaller and we have an
infinite number of these disks and that
means we're just going to take a
definite integral so we're going to take
the definite integral of this from A to
B and this right here is the formula
that you will often see in a calculus
book for using the disk method when
you're rotating around the x axis but I
just wanted to show you that it comes
out of the common sense of finding the
volume of this disk the f of X right
over here is just
the radius of the disk so this this part
right over here is just really PI R
squared we multiply it times the depth
and then we take the sum from A to B
from A to B of all of the discs and it's
really essentially since this is an
integral it's the limit as each of those
discs get narrow narrow narrow and we
have an infinite number of those discs